l'édition les angles diffusée sur nrj12
est dans la tourmente depuis plusieurs
jours et pour cause plusieurs candidats
du pouvoir ont dénoncé le harcèlement
dont elle aurait été victime durant le
tournage
il sortira des termes de genre bah si
c'est pas prêt à le faire il ya deux
mondes cv sur la table depuis le hashtag
boycottent les dangers a été lancé sur
les réseaux sociaux mercredi angèle
rania et natanya bonnet s'exprimer tout
d'abord sur les violences de certains
candidats dans des paquets spécialisée
dans leur scellement donc envers les
femmes s'est approché de moi en disant
j'en ai rien appris de la production tu
vas voir lapidation devant lesquels le
principal intéressé raphaël s'est
défendu hier soir sur notre plateau mois
en outre chacun je me serais permis
d'actionner les versions ne diffère pas
qu'à ce niveau là puisque les trois
filles ont affirmé que la production
fournie est de la drogue aux candidats
une information que raphaël est là
encore totalement démenti et bien sûr
qu'elle ment à ses côtés son aventure
deux interventions et de discours
complètement différent qui interroge
alors polémique des anges
être beauty mangel ou team raphaël ce
soit la candidate qui nous est avec nous
pour nous apporter sa version il fera
face à maxime anciens candidats de the
circle et meilleur ami de raphaël
/
merci à maxime d'être avec nous est un
très bon ami de rappel vous avez fait je
circle france et la bataille des coupes
ouais merci d'être là bon maximus et tpm
paix vous devez vous le dire chez vous
c'est la seule émission on peut
enchaîner kamyshev porte parole des
écolo c'est ça qui fait la force cette
émission j'aurais aussi tueur émoustille
assez bon et on attaque ce qu'on appelle
une personne qu'on appellera max qui a
travaillé en boîte de prod de télé
réalité notamment dans cette boîte de
prod a pas mon genre voilà qui nous dira
tout j'ai connu c'est isabelle morini
bosc
non mais non mais attention dans l'armée
c'est l'anonymat vous allez voir il va
nous dire des trucs de fou sur cette
affaire alors je trouve qu'ils mangent
elles ou team raphaël alors c'est vrai
que tu me raphaël c'est plus team
production parce que raphaël voilà lui
il nous a donné sa version c'est plus la
production de pouvoir qui est mise en
cause par max notre témoin vous king
l'eau vous avez fait beaucoup de télé
réalité oui je crois bien c'est la douce
avait quand même moi je fais c'est comme
rafael nadal à roland garros non mais
c'est humain mais c'était le grand
chelem à des productions vous est-ce que
vous avez des trucs ce que vous avez vu
des trucs qui vous ont choqué et qui
rejoignent ce qu'a dit angèle et ses
deux amis oui tout à fait 120 personnes
alors je vais pas du tout craché dans la
soupe est ce qu on ne sait pas y a pas
de souci ça j'ai su me soigner de ses
blessures et faire la part des choses en
me disant j'ai une qualité d'unique est
pas négligeable sans tout ça n'aurait
pas été possible mais j'ai eu les
épaules pour m'en sortir parce que
psychologiquement j'ai quand même été
détruites après le tournage des anges
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant ce
temps là il ya eu tellement de trucs
large et était quoi les choses qui vous
ont le plus marqué les choses qui m'ont
le plus marqué c'est que
le vocabulaire j'ai reçu des menaces de
mort des menaces d'agressions de
plusieurs candidats et en fait j'avais
mon téléphone le week-end et je les
cache et là mon soutien gorge pour avoir
des preuves je me sentais pas protégés
par la production j'allais les voir
personne est recherchée et ben oui mais
en fait il fallait que j'ai des preuves
je courais les voir en en dessous à la
production ils 0 montant ou dans la
maison je m'en venais me défendre j'ai
peur j'ai zones d'accord je suis pas en
sécurité masqués et des cloches
c'est comme un continent quand tu
manques dans fermé au bout d'un moment
on se classe et ça c'est comme dans le
loft à l'époque mais ça wilsey les
téléspectateurs 10 c'est plutôt normal
après voilà qui est des clash mais des
menaces de mort la saison dernière est
très très loin je vais tout faire une
maison qui pouvaient pas mon cadrés et
donc cgc mais ce téléphone cacher et la
personne qui me bouscule sans rencontre
va prévenir la prod et quand il récupère
nos téléphones et ben quand je les
récupère et le week end après mes deux
téléphones étaient grillés il ne
marchait plus deux iphone mort j'ai pété
un plomb scandale rush un téléphone pour
pour détruire les preuves des menaces
que j'avais enregistrée
d'accord d'accord alors vous avez été
marqué par ça
j'ai été marqué par celle surtout aussi
par une grosse crise d'angoissé que j'ai
fait en tournage et une accumulation à
la tournage des anges et je tremble et
j'arrive plus à contrôler mon corps
j'étais dans un état mais catastrophique
et au lieu de médée j'avais la preuve
devant moi à la caméra devant ma gueule
et je disais en émoi l'hôpital je suis
pas bien je peux plus je peux plus mais
c'était une accumulation là je vous dis
ça comme ça mais c'est super long
entourage et personnes mais des films
est comme ça il me disait rien et il a
fallu que mon corps s'est mis en défense
et je me suis auto calmer tout seul mais
des heures après j'ai cru que j'allais
crever alors vous raf maxime vous vous
êtes plus ce team raphaël ou enfin tim
production vous dit que il ya tout se
passe bien dans cette danse et tournage
de télé réalité alors moi je suis pas
venu ici pour défendre raphaël lac nancy
fanny simplement j'ai participé à une
aventure avec lui qui s'est tourné avant
celle des anges ce que j'ai pu constater
durant cette aventure c'est qu'ils
appellent d'harcèlement c'était
peut-être la même boîte de production
mais ya pas eu de harcèlement il ya eu
des clash
il ya eu des disputes ya eu de l'amo et
eu des rires il ya tout eu mais ya pas
eu d'harcèlement pur et dur mais et
c'est
connaissant raphaël dans cette aventure
là et voyant on va dire la tournure que
ça prend avec les événements
d'aujourd'hui je ne comprends pas
comment et ont connu cette personne dans
ce programme là aujourd'hui il ya une
toute autre facette de lui qui est on va
dire dévoilées au grand dam